Riley Keough shares her final photo
taken with Mom Lisa Marie Presley before
her death I don't know what to do with
myself I'm not if I'm not a mom just
days after Lisa Marie was laid to rest
at Graceland Riley posted the pic to
Instagram in the caption she reflected
on feeling blessed and grateful to have
the snapshot of her last moment spent
with her beautiful mama I'm going to
read something that
my granddaughter
wrote
for all of you Riley didn't speak during
Sunday's memorial service but it was her
grandmother Priscilla and husband Ben
that delivered the words for her
in 1968 she entered our world
she then grew a family of her own
then came her second child
it was time for a tragedy
she knew what was close to the end
survivors
guilt some would say but a broken heart
was a doing of her death
now she is home where she always
belonged but my heart is missing her
love
I'm going to read something Riley wrote
a letter to my mama
thank you for being my mother in this
life I am eternally grateful to have
spent 33 years with you
I'm certain I chose the best mother for
me in this world and I knew that as far
back as I can remember you
she's so level-headed and I love her and
I don't know what to say she's much
further advanced than I ever was over
the years Lisa Marie's shared her awe
and admiration for her first born
daughter with E.T many times I'm
constantly impressed by her as Riley
forged a career in acting Lisa Marie
couldn't help but gleam at her
daughter's passion she's doing it for
the right reason she's doing it for the
art she's not doing it because so she
wants to like somehow do it and have a
life so you know she's she's got a good
gauge on her uh with people and I you
know I am very protective and worried
but I don't get in the way I've always
like sort of let her do her thing she
works been working since 13 very hard
and I admire her greatly she proved to
be Riley's biggest fan normally I stay
away okay because she's so you know
serious about her work so um this time
was my like I said can I come tonight
can I actually be there but I was like
you're my daughter you're in the movie I
will love it I'll just be watching you
and all the whole time and I'm just so
proud of her I don't even know what to
say I'm so proud before Lisa Marie's
death she Riley and the Presley family
honored the legacy of her father Elvis
when they imprinted their hands outside
the TLC Chinese Theater in Hollywood
this is just a huge honor for us to
speak for me and my family and my
children
um
biggest honor we're so grateful this is
a it's such a an amazing honor um
to be able to do it with my sisters and
my mother and my grandmother and it's
really emotional to to have people care
so much to to about your family
[Music]